[Applause]
uber which is one of the best shows i've
seen in so long oh thank you um you
founded this company um called hit
record
will you please tell us about it okay so
well it started before it was a company
at all it was just this thing i was
doing together with my brother yeah yeah
when i wanted to make little art
different than show business like little
songs or stories or videos of stuff i
was making and he helped me set up a
little website to put it on there and
then this community started forming on
the website and we all started making
things together and so now it's grown a
lot and it's a company and we still make
things together and we've made big shows
and won awards and published books and
stuff like that um well since you bring
people together through art i was
wondering we've never done this before
on the show um we could uh do a little
project of our own ready okay okay it's
masterpiece in a minute
all right
it's very simple we're gonna go for one
minute put the uh clock on um and
together we can draw one another okay we
have one minute i'm gonna draw you and
you'll draw me okay
all right ready one two three go okay
okay who is um an actor
that you wish you could work with again
an actor i wish i could work with again
um don cheadle
oh i love him i did a movie with him and
zoe deschanel's actually when i met zoe
before we did 500 days of summer
together
oh the best movie ever oh thank you now
you played an extraterrestrial
um and i was in an extraterrestrial
movie do you believe in
extraterrestrials that's it what are you
wearing on your shirt wait i'm i'm too
busy drawing horses okay oh my god
details
okay oh god 20 seconds off dude 20
seconds
romantic in real life a hopeless
romantic yes absolutely of course uh
because romance is really like what else
is there if there's not romance right oh
god i know your family your whole story
is so beautiful okay inception was about
hacking into dreams what's the strangest
dream you've had lately the strangest
dream i've had lately the the scary ones
have spiders
oh okay thank you oh
sorry
god darn it i'm drawing a big what do
you think of mine how big your heart is
oh my god oh my god
here's my real one
[Applause]
why do i have one tooth what am i a baby
i only have time can you imagine me as
like a 13 month old is that what this is
a little bit like i don't know i just i
i had only time for one two okay i see
you ran out of time you had to ask the
question i didn't want you to be
toothless yeah
one represents all no no one means i'm
toothless you could have just left out
the teeth and then no one would notice
okay y'all dad
does this make it better pretty good
right
oh okay
that is so much work
why did you cross it out now i'm missing
the tune
keep going
okay that's much better
um
joseph gordon levitt i mean as if we
just couldn't all
love you more oh thank you drew phew
okay
super pump the battle for uber air
sunday
at 10 pm on show time get on the theater
and we'll be right back
[Applause]
[Music]